en europe ce week end pierre de vilno
bonjour aurélien pradié bonjour merci
d'être en ligne avec nous vous êtes
secrétaire général des républicains
sophie petrona a passé sa première nuit
en france cette libération c'est une
victoire pour la france
libération est toujours une bonne
nouvelle je m'en réjouis parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'autre raison que s'en réjouir
pour moi c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
notre pays c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
l'otage c'est une bonne nouvelle pour sa
famille et voilà pourquoi je considère
que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour notre
pays
elle veut y retourner au mali vous lui
dites quoi à cette dame je le dis que
son pays c'est la france
mais son choix reste le sien je pense
que nous ne sommes pas encore au moment
où il faut tirer toutes les conclusions
des conditions de cette libération et de
ce que l'ex-otage peut avoir à l'esprit
mais je pense que au moment où l'on est
libéré on remet les pieds sur le sol de
sa patrie la france
je pense que le premier message adressé
un message de remerciements à son pays à
la france je pense que les français
seraient heureux d'abord de l'entendre
remercier son pays la france
représentait au mali pour saper pour les
conditions de justement de deux gains de
paix dans ce pays qui a été fracturée
pendant pendant des années on pense aux
5000 sens militaires français qui sont
sur place
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous leur
dites quand quand je regarde ça cette
libération
et voilà pourquoi je vous disais que
l'ex-otage a aujourd'hui une
responsabilité importante qui est aussi
de s'adresser aux forces armées à
l'ensemble des acteurs français qui vont
certainement perdu la vie dans les
combats au mali elle a une
responsabilité qui est désormais aussi
une responsabilité politique et j'ai été
personnellement dérange et peut-être de
ne pas l'avoir plus remercié son pays
mais je ne veux pas le juger parce qu'au
moment où un montage reviennent en son
pays
j'imagine qu'elle a en tête mille autres
choses que cela je dis simplement
aujourd'hui que il faut qu'elles aient
conscience que sa parole est aussi une
parole politique et tout à l'heure le
spécialiste antoine glaser nous
parlait d'une éventuelle réconciliation
avec le mali à propos de réconciliation
dans vos rangs depuis la révélation du
secret de polichinelle comme quoi
françois baroin ne sera pas candidat à
la présidentielle ça y est les lions
sont lâchés dans l'arène
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il n'ya aucune discipline la droite
est fracturée divisé alors ma question
aurélien pradié parce que vous en avez
plus ou moins parler de manière assez
cash est ce que vous avez choisi votre
club de surf nos pays bas ce nom je n'ai
pas choisi mon club de surf au pays
basque pour une raison simple c'est que
je crois que la droite républicaine peut
revenir aux responsabilités je crois que
si notre famille politique tire toutes
les leçons des échecs passés celui des
présidentielles celui des européennes
elle peut renouer avec la victoire
mais pour le faire il faut que nous
tirions toutes les leçons sereinement
tranquillement de ce qui n'a pas réussi
par le passé
je pense que les primaires n'ont pas
réussi par le passé on a eu le sentiment
que c'était une réussite
sauf que ça nous a divisés ça nous a
rétréci et ça n'a pas permis de
s'adresser à l'ensemble du peuple
français et je pense aussi que le projet
politique que nous portions lors des
dernières élections présidentielles lors
des dernières élections européennes ne
correspondait pas à la volonté
d'espérance d'espoir que les français
pouvaient attendre d'une droite juste et
d'une droite populaire et lorsque je dis
cela je ne fait au fond sa personne
j'essaie simplement de ne pas me cacher
derrière mon petit doigt de ne pas être
faux cul ou hypocrite il le dire donc
que la droite doit renouer avec une
vision populaire et pas avec une vision
rétrécie
alors ne soyons pas focus je reprends
vos termes aurélien pradié pas de
primaire
non pour moi pas de primaires c'est une
décision qui reviendra aux adhérents et
je ne prétends pas parler à la place des
adhérents et la primaire un double un
double effet problématique le premier
c'est que ça fabrique une course de
petits chevaux salle fabrique une course
ou petites ambitions personnelles alors
que nous avons besoin d'une ambition
collective voyez bien depuis plusieurs
semaines et c'est ce que j'ai voulu dire
les uns et les autres s'énervent sur
leur potentiel candidature aux primaires
tout ça parce qu'il ya le spectre des
primaires et je pense que c'est d'abord
une rencontre d'un candidat avec les
français la primaire elle fabrique un
chef de clan a un chef d'état voilà le
problème
mais quand même il faut que ce soit un
carnet et et même votre patron christian
jacob il
source europe 1 à 10 finalement à sonia
mabrouk qu au bout d'un questionnement
assez assez progressif qu' il y aura un
choix des militants sur une personne art
comment il va se faire ce choix comme il
s'est déjà fait depuis de nombreuses
années seul il y avait une histoire
avant la primaire la primaire c'est pas
l'histoire de la droite républicaine la
primaire c'est une parenthèse à
l'occasion de laquelle d'ailleurs même
des gens de gauche sont venus chanter
pour dire à quel point c'était une
anomalie c'est ça c'est ça le problème
c'est qu'il ya déjà sur guesnes non pas
seulement je lis le vrai problème de la
primaire une fois de plus c'est qu'elle
a rétrécit le champ
enfin chacun peut comprendre que la
grande ambition la droite républicaine
c'est pas d'être seulement une petite
boutique
la grande ambition de droite
républicaine comme en 95 avec jacques
chirac
comme en 2007 avec nicolas sarkozy ses
dents portait le peuple français pas
seulement le peuple de droite le peuple
français et on ne peut pas commencer une
histoire avec le peuple français en
commençant l'histoire avec un
rétrécissement sur seulement notre
petite boutique elle est passionnante
donc petite boutique jean gilles
secrétaire général et je pense que c'est
de là que peuvent partir beaucoup
d'idées beaucoup de projets pour
l'avenir et je dis aussi que notre
grande boutique nous la droite
républicaine c'est la france et c'est
l'ensemble des français vous ne l'avez
pas nommé mais celui qui parle beaucoup
des primaires c'est bruno retailleau est
ce qu'il y a un problème retailleau chez
les républicains comme à l'époque il y
avait eu un problème sion non il n'y a
pas de problème retailleau moi j'ai dit
à moins de retailleau ce que j'avais à
lui dire je lui ai dit notamment
je critique notamment que de l'entendre
parler de la vieille droit de la broche
d'arreau de la droite d'en bas
ce n'était pas correct et dont j'ai
répondu à cela un peu sèchement mais
parce que je suis jeune type du
sud-ouest et que nous dans le sud ouest
on se parle franchement c'est une
manière de se respecter
mais je dis aussi que bruno retailleau
nous avons beaucoup de chance d'avoir
bruno retailleau dans notre famille
politique et que je suis conscient que
je suis certain que vous allez
retailleau a conscience qu'il ya
beaucoup de chances de nous avoir dans
sa famille politique
et pour cela il faut que les uns et les
autres nous parlions que nous apprenions
nos erreurs passées et que nous nous
recommencions pas voilà tout simplement
ce que j'ai dit mais quand vous dites de
renault retailleau qu'il représente la
droite du passé quelle chance quelle
chance ça représente quelles sont les
qualités de bruno retailleau pour votre
formation politique mais nous avons tous
des qualités bruno retailleau en a et je
suis certain que bono retailleau c'est
que nous avons nous aussi des qualités
et donc capables difficulté sur ce on
peut se parler franchement le sujet
parce que vous me donnez pas d'exemples
précis est ce que on doit exclure à
jamais une candidature de nicolas
sarkozy parce que ça c'est un nom qui
revient aussi nicolas sarkozy a dit lui
même que il ne rentrait plus dans le jeu
partisan et donc mais un fait confirmé
jeudi par le passé puis finalement il
est revenu
écoutez je ne sais pas tout ce que je
sais j'essaie de l'expliquer le plus
sereinement possible
c'est que y compris les débats que nous
avons avec les uns et les autres sont
pas les débats de personnes sont les
débats de projets politiques comprennent
bien que lorsque alléger les discussions
y compris que j'ai avec bonheur
retailleau c'est pas l'un contre l'autre
c'est parce que je souhaite que nous
réfléchissions un nouveau projet
politique
nous le faisons déjà autour de christian
jacob depuis plusieurs mois et ça nous
réussit plutôt bien puisqu'elle a réussi
notamment à gagner les élections
municipales
continuons sur cette voie là justement
sur les projets politiques la droite
classique n'a plus le monopole sur le
régalien gérald arman à la tête d'un
ministère régalien est aux manettes avec
des propositions chocs et qu'à voir ses
déclarations sur le séparatisme de le
côté on a un rassemblement national
toujours aussi présent sans compter
l'hypothétique candidature de marion m'a
réussi alors comment on fait dans tout
ça eh bien on travaille sur un projet
nouveau moi je crois que emmanuel macron
est une illusion à tous égards
je pense que vous trouviez société
l'heure où les siens il a tué le
politique
il a tué cette idée que le politique
pouvait transformer la société
changer les choses il est au fond d'un
conformisme banal considère que le
politique est là pour accompagner la
fatalité de la mondialisation proposer
l'apprentissage de la langue arabe à
l'école parce qu'il y aurait une montée
de ces communautés l'a proposée ne rien
proposer sur la modification notre
modèle économique
avoir une vision profondément tu es
injuste de la société et sur le régalien
tout ça est une comédie considérable
vous allez bien gérald darmanin il
s'agite il s'emballe mais il n'y a rien
de concret qu'il soit fait et donc je
pense que la droite républicaine peut
incarner une vraie volonté de
transformation de la société de reprise
en main de notre destin et je pense que
la droite doit être une droite jeu
je le dis parce que c'est pour cela que
je me suis engagé dans cette famille
politique il ya quelques années je crois
la droite qui est capable de protéger
les femmes sur les violences conjugales
ce que j'ai fait depuis quelques mois à
l'assemblée nationale de parler des
questions du handicap de parler de nos
questions de souveraineté notamment sur
la question agricole de re parler
d'écologie qui ne soit pas une punition
permanente
c'est ce que je tâche de faire avec le
tour de france de l'environnement qui
bref de renouer avec un projet optimiste
pour la société et un projet ferme sur
les questions essentielles notamment les
questions d'immigration
là où emmanuel macron parle beaucoup
mais ne fait rien merci aurélien pradié
secrétaire général des républicains
merci d'avoir été